cette vidéo est sponsorisé par north vpn
le multivers est lancée et un nouveau
problème se présente à vous c'est que la
réalité 6311 possède un catalogue de
films et de séries que vous n'avez pas
dans votre réalité 616 et bien opter
pour north vpn grâce à notre vpn en un
clic et ce depuis n'importe où où vous
pouvez changer votre localisation pour
accéder au contenu de n'importe quel
endroit regarder cette réalité
alternative
appelé canada et bien en changeant votre
localisation pour là bas vous aurez
accès à avengers endgame sur dix n'est
plus par exemple d'ailleurs north dpn
possède une vitesse d'exécution
incroyable grâce à ses cinq mille 200
serveurs répartis dans 60 pays est
accessible via six appareils différents
à la fois six appareils qui seront
protégés contre les criminels et la
surveillance plus de raison de
s'inquiéter du le tronc du coup toute
votre activité en ligne sera protégé
alors si vous voulez maîtriser votre
activité et accéder au réseau internet
mondial profitez de l'offre north vpn et
bénéficier de l'offre sur deux ans avec
quatre mois offert un prix nettement
réduit et 30 jours satisfait ou
remboursé en cliquant sur le lien
disponible en descriptions merci à north
vpn
bien le trailer est sorti depuis
maintenant plus d'un mois et il ya
encore énormément de choses à dire nous
n'avons pas encore pris assez le temps
d'en discuter et j'aimerais aujourd'hui
vous faire part de mes réflexions
concernant les sinistres 6 un sujet très
délicat et très complexe car au final
c'est tout à fait inédit tellement de
choses sont possibles avec les sinistres
6 que ce soit la composition de l'équipe
le lien avec les films passés ou tout
simplement leur utilité scénaristique
bref je vous invite à réfléchir avec moi
à de potentiels réponse les entourant
malgré la présence du potentiel groupe
des sinistres 6 dans no et home je reste
partisan de l'idée qu'il y aura une
sorte de méchant principal ou un petit
peu à part et pour aller encore plus
loin je vous dirais même que ce fameux
méchant il y à déjà moyen de resserrer
l'étau pour définir qui il pourrait être
tout d'abord si nous remettons un peu de
contexte le trailer de spider man no way
home nous montre que le sortilège de
steven strange semble avoir pour
conséquence de créer une sorte de
perturbations dans l'espace temps une
perturbation qui va résulter de
l'apparition de vilains très iconique de
spider man qui sembleraient ton déjà
existé dans deux précédents films
d'après les images docteur octopus le
bouffon vert et électro sont clairement
identifiables et la vie populaire
trancherait pour un retour de l'homme
sable et du lézard pour compléter le
groupe c'est vraiment la base de la base
de ce sur quoi nous pouvons nous baser
pour le moment et maintenant que nous
nous sommes remis en tête le trailer de
noé home j'aimerais que nous nous
tournions vers la construction des films
de spider man dans le mc ainsi que de
ses trailer et par extension du coût de
la limite des accords entre sony et
marvel les films spider man du marvel
cinématiques universe sont vraiment
particulier tout simplement car deux
studios ont le nez dans le même projet
pour rappel sony qui a racheté il ya
très longtemps les droits de spider man
près de ce dernier et du coup tout ce
qui touche également son histoire et son
univers à disney qui eux vont intégrer
tout ça dans leur univers
cinématographique cependant c'est là que
c'est intéressant ces accords nous donne
à chaque fois un film qui suit des
règles bien précises prenons l'exemple
de homecoming peter est accompagné d'un
héros du mc eu effet face à un méchant
iconique de spider man en l'occurrence
ici tony stark qui sert de figure
autoritaire et où paternel et le vautour
et si nous prenons far from home nous
retrouvons exactement ce même schéma
peter est accompagné de nick fury un
personnage emblématique du mc eu qui
sert de figure autoritaire et au
paternel et le méchant du film et
mystérieux un méchant emblématiques de
l'univers de spider man appartenant à
sony et ce genre de schéma si l'on
creuse un petit peu révèle pas mal de
détails très important du style même si
nous sommes dans le marvel cinématiques
universe eh bien il ya toujours une
seule figure emblématique présente dans
le film seul tony stark joue un rôle
vraiment important et est physiquement
présent parmi toute la panoplie de super
héros du mc eu dans homecoming et c'est
pareil pour nick fury dans far from
du coup par extension si l'on se réfère
à spider man 3 docteur strange ou le fit
du m6 où la figure paternelle et ou
autoritaires puis tout le reste sera
constitué d'éléments du spyder vers sony
verse laissant donc toute la place pour
l'histoire de peter qui essaie
d'instaurer sony dans le mc hugh alors
si l'on réfléchit logiquement et bien
normalement il n'y est pas censé y avoir
de méphisto ou de dark docteur strange
en tant que grande menace du film ce
sont des théories que vous avez
certainement entendu comme quoi méphisto
serait derrière tout le film avec la
répétition de l'arc one more day des
comics qui correspond parfaitement à
l'histoire qu'essaie de nous vendre le
trailer ou bien le fait que doctor
strange est différent car il s'agirait
d'un autre docteur strange d'une autre
réalité un strange bien plus sombre et
bien pour moi c'est quelque chose
d'impossible par rapport aux accords et
à la cohérence de la construction des
films de spider man dans le mc ou sony a
la mainmise sur les films spider man
dans le mc hugh et il est évidemment
hors de question pour eux qu'une menace
appartenant à disney et marvel studios
volent la vedette aux personnages et aux
vilains du sony verse lié à spider man
et ce dans un film spider man dédié et
c'est tout à fait pareil du côté disney
il est hors de question pour eux de
grille et de grosses cartes comme
méphisto qui a deux mende possibilité de
revenir dans de futures productions
beaucoup plus libre ce que je veux dire
dans des productions plus libre c'est
des productions leur appartenant à 100%
des productions où justement ils n'ont
pas sony dans les pattes et du coup ils
n'ont pas les mains liées pour
introduire un méchant tel méphisto bref
est ce que vous comprenez ce que je veux
dire donc si l'on suit toute cette
logique nous pouvons balayé toutes les
idées comme quoi il y aurait un méchant
caché appartenant à disney
qui apparaîtrait dans le film après je
préfère le préciser mais je ne parle pas
des scène post générique ça c'est encore
un cas à part on va dire je parle
vraiment du film en lui-même de spider
man 3 nos héros et pour continuer
j'aimerais que nous nous tournions
maintenant vers les bandes annonces
enfin le terme plus exact serait les
official teaser trailer des films
spiderman du mc hugh comme je vous le
disais le schéma est toujours le même
pour les films et si ça l'est pour les
films saleh pour les teaser trailer
aussi et vous allez voir qu'il ya là
aussi moyen de déceler certaines
informations si nous prenons l'official
teaser trailer de homecoming
la vidéo commence sur la situation
initiale du film l'ambiance que va nous
instauré ce dernier le point de départ
en somme puis nous enchaînons sur la
présence du caméo du m6 ou qui est ici
tony stark puis nous terminons sur un
gros focus du vautour pour far from home
nous commençons sur le fameux voyage de
peter en europe qui est clairement la
situation initiale du film puis apparaît
soudainement nick fiori qui endort ned
le fameux caméo m6 ou du film et nous
terminons sur la présence appuyée de
mystérieux et du coup si l'on retourne
sur le trailer de spider man aux arômes
nous sommes face exactement au même
schéma peter fait sa vie avec mj et
subit son drama médiatique puis vient
strange avec son fameux sort le caméo du
m6 ou comme vous l'avez compris et nous
terminons sur les sinister 6 mai nos
terminons sur un en particulier
c'est docteur octopus et ce n'est
vraiment pas anodin par exemple si nous
reprenons le trailer de far from home
les éléments taux était à la base
présentés comme de véritables menaces du
film mais dans l'échelle de l'intensité
du trailer ils sont montrés juste avant
l'arrivée très appuyé de mystérieux
chose que l'on retrouve avec le docteur
octopus qui apparaît après les autres
vilains et qui conclut le trailer de nos
héros est bon je le rajoute comme ça
mais j'ai peur que vous me disiez que
j'aille un petit peu trop loin c'est un
détail
et quand mystérieux apparaît et c'est
pareil pour octopus la musique s'arrête
et ils disent une phrase qui est
clairement souligné justement par cette
fameuse coupure de l'eau ester
et partant de tout ça cela signifierait
donc docteur octopus serait le méchant
principal
du film par rapport à ces découpages de
trailer et par extension encore une fois
si l'on retourne sur les films cela
signifierait donc que nos héros me
s'ouvrirait sur une scène lié à octopus
le mettant en scène et l'introduisant
pour le film puisque les autres films
spiderman du mc ou dans leur déroulement
s'ouvre avec une scène introduisant le
méchant du film or cela créerait quand
même une petite incohérence si l'on suit
cette idée générale car docteur strange
semble amener l'élément perturbateur qui
va faire que les sinistres six vont
apparaître et pour le bon déroulement du
scénario ce serait un peu bizarre de
démarrer sur une conséquence de la
perturbation de l'espace temps alors que
cette même perturbation n'est pas encore
arrivé dans le film
mais du coup c'est bien beau tout ça pas
de méchants appartenant à disney et
docteur octopus en tant que méchant
principal ce qui d'ailleurs est très a
cure et 1 par rapport aux comics puisque
dans les comics c'est bel et bien dr
octopus qui créé le premier groupe des
sinistres 6 mais bref c'était un aparté
au final qui serait le potentiel
sinister 6e manquants et bien je vous
avoue que j'ai une petite idée une
petite théorie lié à ça si l'on suit les
productions de sony pictures lié à
spider man donc hors jeu vidéo seulement
les films et bien on remarque que sony
la plupart du temps souhaitent que leurs
vilains soit différent à chaque oeuvre
et c'est très révélateur alors
évidemment le canoë womé particulier car
ils ramèneraient d'anciens méchant
iconique liés aux cinq précédents films
mais nous parlons vraiment du potentiel
sixième membre du groupe qui pour moi
doit suivre la lignée de ses deux
compères des deux précédents films si
l'on prend la trilogie de sam raimi nous
avons le bouffon vert docteur octopus
venom et l'homme sable alors je l'admets
d'entrée venom est un petit peu
l'exception à la règle puisqu'il revient
avec tom hardy mais bon il revient plus
en tant que anti héros si l'on prend les
yeux mais zing spider man nous avons
donc le lézard électro le rhino et le
bouffon vert également mais bon c'est
harry osborn derrière et celui de sam
raimi c'est norman osborn et le harry du
sam raimi verse était plutôt un anti
héros est un allié de peter qu'un
méchant donc voilà c'est une variante du
bouffon vert on va dire et cela a son
importance puisque si l'on se tourne
vers spider man in touch spyder verse
nous faisons face à des variations de
vilains de spider-man différents de ceux
déjà connus comme la version féminine de
octopus ou bien un bouffon vert
clairement monstrueux toujours ce désir
de proposer des méchants différents en
revanche nous pouvons compter kingpin
alias wilson fisk qui est l'antagoniste
principal et si nous nous tournons vers
les nouvelles productions nous avons dû
couver nomme comme on disait
précédemment carnage qui arrive dans
venom de heikki est un méchant de spider
man mort bus qui arrive en 2022 et
kraven le chasseur en 2023 sans oublier
évidemment le vautour et mystérieux
introduit dans le mcs a fait un bon
paquet de méchants déjà et donc
poursuivre cette même vibe il faudrait
donc pour moi un méchant de spider man
que l'on n'a pas encore vu dans les
films la première idée aurait été
pourquoi pas mister négatives dans le
trailer de nos héros mnu voyons à un
moment donné spy dit traverser une sorte
de soupe populaire lors d'une possible
fuite et bien si nous regardons
attentivement la scène il semblerait que
cette soupe populaire ferait partie de
l'organisation du fist alors rien à voir
avec ce que vous pouvez imaginer le fils
est en gros une sorte de refuge une
sorte d'organisation bienfaisante qui
aident les sans abri des gens dans le
besoin et cetera sauf que cette dernière
est une couverture géré par mr négative
un très grand criminel qui s'est battu à
maintes reprises avec spider man vous en
faites ce que vous voulez moi
personnellement je penche plutôt pour
une référence une sorte d'histoire aig à
l'univers des comics car son histoire ne
s'adaptent pas forcément avec nos mais
comme il n'a pas fait partie des
sinistres 6 bref néanmoins cette
référence est là la seconde idée aurait
été mort lounes le cas de marc launay
très intéressant car il est le méchant
qui va donner naissance à l'unification
des spider man provenant d'une autre
réalité ce dernier traque les araignées
totem avec sa famille à travers le
multivers ce qui va le conduire dans la
réalité de peter parker et lui faire
rencontrer d'autres araignée qui vont
l'aider à vaincre leurs ennemis communs
même si morlhonnais en soi très complexe
a adapté pour le film il pourrait être
la menace hachez conduisant les spider
man à se faire attraper par leurs
ennemis ultime et surtout il est il me
semble le seul véritable ennemi à être
liés aux réalités et aux multi vers ce
qui colle parfaitement avec nos héros et
enfin il est temps de le mentionner le
scorpion peut-être que mcgann n'était
qu'un easter egg dans homecoming
pourtant il a bel et bien été introduit
et il est présent dans la scène post
générique du film là où le vautour
semble avoir accepté sa sentence mcgann
alias le scorpion est quant à lui
toujours à la recherche de l'araignée et
souhaite prendre sa revanche jamais
véritablement introduit sur grand écran
car oui dans spider man in to the spider
verse il s'agit d'un scorpion alternatif
et non de l'origine elle est bien magan
aligne les étoiles pour nos armes
puisque en plus de ce que je viens de
vous dire il est un ennemi récurrent de
spider man ce dernier a même fait partie
des sinistres 6 et marvel n'est pas du
genre à introduire des personnages et à
les laisser sur le bas côté tout est
justifié mais le plus intéressant et
qu'en plus d'être un méchant de sony qui
pourrait créer de la nouveauté comme
pour le vautour et mystérieux et bien
l'histoire du scorpion pourrait
clairement être adapté à l'écran dans no
et home engagé par jonah jameson ce
dernier devait espionner peter parker
pour comprendre pourquoi ce dernier
réussissait à faire de belles photos de
spider man n'ayant jamais réussi à
prendre peter en flagrant délit à cause
du sens d'araignée qui mettait en alerte
le héros jameson en colère a financé une
expérience pour faire de mcg argane le
scorpion afin qu'ils traquent spider man
une expérience qui va changer mcgann à
jamais le rendant fou et créant donc une
nouvelles menaces criminelles pour le
monde
introduit dans la scène post générique
de far from home jonah jameson est celui
qui va révéler publiquement l'identité
de spider man dans le but de le faire
couler et si nous regardons
attentivement le trailer de noé home
nous pouvons voir que jameson semble
entretenir cette chasse à l'araignée
pour que tout le monde soit contre
spider man nous le voyons sur de
multiples écrans de la ville montrant
peter parker comme l'ennemi public
numéro un et plus on avance plus il
semblerait que ce dernier prenne de
l'importance ce que je veux dire par là
c'est que totalement absents de
homecoming ce dernier apparaît dans far
from home en caméo pour semble-t-il
avoir plus d'importance dans no et home
notamment par rapport aux dramas
médiatique de spider man jameson n'étant
pas toujours morale et étant lié à la
création du scorpion il se pourrait que
dans nos héros mme johnson est sorti
mcguigan de prison sachant que ce
dernier voue une haine envers l'araignée
dans le but de le capturer pour le
traîner en justice voire de le tuer
c'est une idée qui permettrait d'amener
un nouvel ennemi de spider man encore
jamais vu à l'écran et qui avait été
teasé ainsi que de donner plus d'impact
à jameson avec une menace liée du coup
au drama médiatique qui doit se résoudre
à la fin du film par exemple dans les
comics la création du scorpion va se
faire savoir et jameson sera obligé de
démissionner de son poste si mystérieux
a souhaité faire tomber peter après sa
mort c'est bel et bien jonah jameson
aujourd'hui l'ennemi médiatique de
spider man défendant mystérieux
il était temps de faire un gros point
sur le cas des sinistres 6 dans spider
man from et je me suis très content de
l'avoir fait j'espère que la vidéo du
coup vous aura plu évidemment il ya
encore énormément de choses à dire sur
le film et en particulier sur les
sinistres 6 il ya plein de choses que je
n'ai pas mentionné spécialement mais on
n'oublie pas par exemple que docteur
octopus et méchant simplement car il est
contrôlé par ses bras et si toby maguire
il ya et bien le peter parker joué par
toby c'est justement ce cas de figure
octopus est on va dire le seul
antagonistes du groupe qui est un
méchant malgré lui c'est à cause de ses
bras mécanique et pareil pour l'homme
sable peut-être que nous l'aurons en
tant que vilain dans une première partie
du film mais il faut aussi prendre cette
information compte c'est que l'homme
sable est le seul des sinistres six à
avoir fait partie des avengers après
donc voilà on tout ça pour dire que il
ya plein de choses il ya plein de
détails on aura des surprises des
retournements de vestes des
retournements de situation et peut-être
qu'il y aura même beaucoup plus de
méchants que les si mr 6 peut-être ils
seront plus de 6 bref marvel et sony
nous cache bien des secrets voilà ce
qu'il faut en conclure nous aurons
l'occasion de reparler de spider man aux
ehome prochainement en attendant
n'hésitez pas à me faire part de vos
réflexions et de vos idées en
commentaire c'est toujours un plaisir de
vous lire et surtout que le sujet est
parfait pour le débat n'hésitez pas non
plus à laisser un petit pouce bleus
c'est important et surtout surtout à
vous abonner à la chaîne pour ne louper
aucune des prochaines vidéos allez on se
retrouve très vite merci à tous que le
line up soit avez-vous 7 et argo rock
ciao tout le monde
[Musique]